hello how are you
welcome to PlayStation grenade fortnight
season seven has been with us for long
enough for players to have settled into
their London routines this means we can
highlight locations you can utilize for
relatively safe starts and hopefully
those easy wins all location times are
in the description below and of course
my super secret loop run is the last one
on the list so you stay for longer fYI
these are tactical drops to give you the
edge in battle which will give you good
loot the ability to scout your enemies
from a safe distance and great rotations
to pick and choose battles as the storm
closes in too much talking let's do this
by the way use code a damaru when using
the shop and get a shout out like these
awesome guys whoo let's crack on
[Music]
this is my personal favorite spot in
season seven in the opening cinematic
for season seven the iceberg brought in
the nutcrackers home which can be found
here on the map inside is a triple
chests barn of course that requires a
little orangey look and again of course
I have no look for close by there's an
outpost to loot this location is
swimming in material so grab loads so
you're ready for your next sweaty build
battle my suggestion here is to travel
towards frosty flights and see if there
are any planes left I've noticed by the
time you've looted and grabbed those
materials and got your backside down to
frosty flights the location is pretty
empty and everyone has moved on all
there's only one person left who thinks
they are safe and don't expect to be
shot without warning another suggestion
I have is that if there is a plane still
around wait until the very last second
to use it even if you're in a fight
depending on meds bide your time and
have faith in the speed a plane can
rescue you from the tick of the storm
and of course use your heals out on the
wing to both travel and med at the same
time in general the sheer beauty of
being the last one out of the storm and
in a plane means you can pick and choose
your next engagements in this example I
didn't take a single bullet after I
healed out of the storm I was behind
everyone the whole time and quickly took
advantage of players never looking
behind them in the final circle I have
to admit I went a bit try hard as I
wanted to prove how simple winning in
this manner is even when in the storm
and the safe zone is at the other side
of the map so yeah I toured up like a
sweaty twitch streamer and the last
person was kind enough to just kill
themselves lovely
so to recap nutcrackers house beeline
over to frosty flights arrived in the
zone as late as possible take the high
ground win rinse and repeat
so the second spot gives varied results
the outpost
overlooking pleasant Park if you've seen
the videos I make in previous seasons
you'll know that I adore the hotel
nearby this location but in season seven
I found far too much action there to
call it a safe drop so I began to drop
on the outpost above the main reason is
simple it's all about those planes with
one of these beasts you'll be able to
get to any storm circle with ease my
main reason for landing here are those
almighty sight lines of pleasant park
and the motel from here we can spot
anyone and relay that information to our
squad mates it's also fantastic the
partying other players and taking their
eliminations without them realizing
where the hell you are as the season
progresses and depending on the bus
direction it's likely more people will
drop here
if that happens ignore the chests and
grab a gun as soon as possible it's not
certain but you should be able to take
down the other players good luck with
that one
from this point if you're an aggressive
player get your ass into pleasant and
blindside everyone in this game we came
out of Pleasant with 9 eliminations I've
barely fought anyone but I know that's
not for everyone it's not really me if
I'm completely honest unless I'm trying
to hang on to the coattails of other
players who have far beyond my skill
level for us mere mortals our options
are more about preservation to stay
completely out of the action take a
plane north up to this area of the map
and loot in peace on my personal
preference move on to the motel area and
after cleaning up there take the rifts I
hate planes by the way I tend to avoid
them as much as I can but I realize how
important they are in season 7
[Music]
each of these landing spots is all about
having the most options available to
rotate to another area a small but
reliable spot to think about going to is
this new location up in the Northeast
next to the ever-changing block this is
homestead hanger let's point out the
obvious first there's a plane here
depending on the content of the block
it's the only one here for miles around
so it's invaluable in terms of loop
drops we have five chests
Tolu here at the homestead one in the
silo two in the house one in the back of
a car and one hiding in the back of the
hangar going over to the ice cream truck
could yield two more and there's also
one at the AAA meeting on the hill eight
chests in about 90 seconds oh and
remember the architects house it's had
an upgrade it's now made of brick and
has four more chests if your look holds
out from here you could venture into the
block but keep in mind it will be
changing regularly over the season
there's also a kicker to dropping at
Homestead hangar should someone steal
your plane off for some reason it
doesn't spawn in there are rifts north
to keep you moving anywhere the storm
forces you so for a small starting point
it's pretty damn impressive
[ __ ] season 1 I love to drop over the
caravan park with truckasaurus standing
over there let's call it the caravan
campsite to keep with the naming
conventions well in season 7 this place
has real potential again and it's the
first one on the list where you have to
do a little bit of traveling to get to a
plane but it's definitely possible to
grab one
but first let's recount the chests on
offer there's two in the roof of the
main building which is a great starting
point in the caravan area there's loads
of ammo drops and random weaponry to
grab and traveling north should yield
yet another chest here's where you have
an option off six to make stay and take
all the metal on offer if you're playing
the screams match maybe push into retail
row there really is quite a few options
here
the only real disadvantage to this
location is the hill overlooking lonely
Lodge here is a hot drop zone due to the
plains on offer we could flank around
and take a zip wire up to that spot or
my preference travel south to this hill
with a bunch of rifts on it use this to
rotate anywhere dive-bomb retail row or
maybe take the high ground above lonely
lodge and grab one of those planes - the
options from this spot are multiple
[Music]
over in the snow area of the map is a
super secret rift to uncover this island
here is usually deserted and hold three
chests - in the open and another in the
shack but whilst you're here dig down a
level and you'll find that secret
permittivity be sure to stack up on mats
before leaving or by the way under that
block of ice is another secret bunker
like the one up at whaling Woods so it's
likely this area will far out as the
season goes on maybe they'll be insta
travel between multiple bunkers after
waiting to see from this position I tend
to travel to the cave slightly north and
to further chests inside there's also
one of buff - if you want to go that far
up a good plan is to knock down the
plain inside and although it's a pain in
the ass to set free use it to grab
another plane which is less banged up on
the small island south there's also a
chest on a Ledge nearby and a football
to play with once back in the air you
should be armed to the teeth have a good
amount of mats and be ready to attack
other players from this unexpected
position it's common though not to see
anyone here until you reach the top 10
just remember to take meds if you want
to fight in the storm I can't count how
many times have I killed myself in the
storm so damn close I suggest going to
the ski lodges the chalets or the ice
sculptures nearby for easy looting with
minimal risk that season I suggested a
certain route for early game starting
with a drop at the castle at Haunted
Hills while in season 7 the castle has
been decimated
funny thing is it's still a great spot
for a solo game there's four chests
regularly here the most obvious spawn is
the one in broad daylight but there are
others a little more cryptic
occasionally you won't be alone as one
of the person tends to drop here and
you'll also need to stay aware of planes
deal with them how you see fizz what's
great now though is that the castle
looks so decrepit that it deters players
from landing here but by doing so you'll
have a great plan in place here's what
to do as quickly as possible check the
rifts to the north of the broken Castle
if they aren't there ignore the next
piece of this plan looking around the
castle you're guaranteed to find either
balloons grapples or a launching pad
venture down into Haunted Hills this
place is awesome for loot depending on
the circle make your way back up the
mountain to use those
riffs and rotate into the next circle so
many options here the outpost above
Pleasant is still a great point even at
this late stage as there may be one last
plane waiting for you other than that
you can actually make it all the way to
tilted if you pop your umbrella
instantly after using the rift remember
to try and be the last one in the new
circle to maximize your positioning and
those good old easy kills finally I
found a loot run which is my favorite
quick loot system in season 7 which
takes full advantage of zip lines and
allows for checking enemy positions from
afar when dropping from the battle bus
beeline for the mountain with the Dino
bones on top the one above Paradise
Palms is possible for two chests to
appear here coincidentally
over the 10 games I went here to had a
loot llama on this road I know it's
completely random but I thought it was
worth shouting out check out how many
opponents are in Paradise and then take
the zipline south check again for foes
over the junkyard and then pick up these
two chests over by the rocks
next take the zipline to the Winnebago
and potentially two more chests again
look into a popular area this time it's
El Pueblo or you'll probably call it
Westfield if it's empty get in there and
get looting if it isn't and you don't
want the fight take the next three zip
lines like this for the end of the run
this perfect little outpost with three
more chests and most importantly a
lovely aeroplane for your efforts in
around two minutes you should have a
damn good loot and be aware of all your
falls positioning either double back and
loot other areas or venture forward into
battle the world is your oyster up the
thing which is even better about this
beasts route it's actually possible to
complete it later in the game should the
third storm circle be down here use this
loot run to upgrade your loadout and spy
on all your enemy positions
it's bloody great it really is right we
did it a quick point though about all
these landing spots they all have a high
probability of launch pug drops which
are great for late-game they are
invaluable in fact check out this
example I am
the terrible player but I can still use
them to outmaneuver other players and
with potato am as good as mine the win
is assured oh look a streamer and they
must be the console T fou right that'll
do it grommets I'm Adam from PlayStation
grenade if you'd like more fortnight
content please think about liking and
subscribing and using my code in the
shop is by far the best way to support
me I usually appreciate it but you see
you anyway it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time happy holidays
[Music]